six chiots se prépare à semer la panique
à kyoto et tout cela dans un seul but de
renverser le nouveau gouvernement qui
auto est une ville dangereuse
jamais je ne te laisserai les là bas il
est de mon devoir de l'arrêter merci
pour ce que tu m'as apporté au revoir
simon rhin refuse de nous aider notre
pays court à sa perte
ici jamais qu'il retrouvait le goût de
tuer le japon est sur le point de
sombrer dans le chaos pense d'abord à ta
vie avant de sauver celle des autres
quand l'ours la surrection
l'accord sera toi attention
tu n'as rien de mieux
reste ici je reviendrai je te le promets
nous reviendrons au temps des jours les
plus sombres de l'insurrection